[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com welcome to the bonus show we
have Rand Paul news remember back at the
end of 2017 when Rand Paul was tackled
by his anesthesiologist neighbor Rene
Boucher and he broke six ribs
he had a bruised lung I believe it was
and he's actually going to require a
hernia related procedure at a hospital
in Canada which was a whole other story
that we did last week or the week before
Rand Paul has now been awarded 580
thousand dollars in damages stemming
from that incident it is broken down as
three hundred and seventy five thousand
in punitive damages two hundred thousand
for pain and suffering and seven
thousand eight hundred and thirty four
dollars for medical expenses Boucher's
attorney says that they are appealing
the damage award so there's a bunch of
different stories here pat one story is
that of is this an incident worthy of
five hundred and eighty thousand dollars
in terms of a settlement and I guess a
jury felt that the answer is yes indeed
there there is the second story is how
much can be collected because as we know
just because there's a verdict with a
certain amount of money there are all
there's a panoply of reasons which
explain why that money is not always
collected by the person to whom it's
awarded and then number three is the
fact that Rand Paul is not a
particularly rich member of the Senate
in fact he's one of the less wealthy
members of the Senate and for him this
five hundred and eighty thousand dollars
which to like a rich senator would be
nothing for Rand Paul this will
potentially increase his net worth by
around fifty percent so it really is
like I'm this is life-changing money for
Rand Paul you know as a Brazilian
Jujitsu white belt I thought it was
important after this came out that Rand
Paul work on his takedown defense he has
to sprawl or get out of the way or pull
guard or something like that now I'm
realizing this was actually quite
lucrative for him I mean it you know it
sucks to get attacked like this and get
your ribs broken and all that
but if that's if you get $600,000 nearly
for that I would take that deal
I grew up growing up you know kids like
to have these games where they say
listen would you take would you take ten
punches without even being able to
defend your face would you take ten
punches from Mike Tyson in exchange for
a million dollars or something like that
and I don't know why I always found it
so grotesque ever since I was a kid like
I never liked engaging in any of that
stuff but people often do think in those
terms like okay if if you said I need to
stand on my front stoop and be tackled I
will suffer a bruised lung a broken six
broken ribs I will have to go to Canada
for hernia surgery and at the tail end
of it I'll get $600,000 like do you
trade that do you accept that I don't
know it's just so weird to think in
those terms to me I like it I honestly
get some joy out of it ten punches from
Mike Tyson for a million dollars I would
say no because after the first or second
punch I would be knocked out and then he
would just be pummeling my unconscious
body thereafter and that could give me
permanent brain damage so I would say no
to that
but getting tackled and some ribs broken
like that stuff can for the most part be
fixed I don't think it'll affect your
longevity or your long-term health so I
would definitely take that for $600,000
especially if it's just I mean it's not
even a trained fighter then you get a
man you geologist next door what about
five million dollars for the ten punches
like at a certain point you get two
numbers where it starts to become
interesting right yeah and that's a
certain point it's money that would
affect not just me but my entire family
and future generations so I would have
to think it over but Mike Tyson in his
prime I'm not messing with that guy
right but the point is what was an
obvious no thirty seconds ago is now oh
you very quickly made it a scenario
where now I am thinking about it anyway
I hate questions like that those kind of
which which would you rather or would
you accept what about removing two
fingers in exchange for free airfare
anywhere you want for the rest
of your life like I I don't know it's
just it's not likely that that would
ever be a decision someone has to make
in those terms so I'd rather just not
even entertain it or think about it
let's talk about the weather
Donald Trump earlier in the week
tweeting that we need global warming
back because it's so cold in the Midwest
in winter of course that's insane and
ignorant but what is true is that this
phenomena known as the polar vortex
which is unleashing extremely cold
conditions in a lot of the US and Canada
but in particular in certain parts of
the United States I think that right now
in Boston it is let me take a look here
it is 12 degrees right now in Boston
we've had worse we've had worse this has
brought up questions about ok I sort of
generally understand that cold days
don't disprove climate change but how
are they actually related and even
though the exact science of it is
certainly beyond me and most of the
people in our audience and definitely
beyond Donald Trump there are now a
number of very interesting reports which
explain the connection between climate
change which can cause both warming of
our oceans and generally what we call
global warming and more record high
temperatures as well as these polar
vortices that can come down and my lay
understanding of it and you tell me Pat
if your assessment is similar is that
when you have parts of the planet
including oceans that are warmer this
relates to creating both temperature
humidity and pressure differences
between areas which can stimulate other
phenomena like polar vortices which
during parts of the year cause these
very very cold streaks to take place
that's generally my understanding of it
although I'm not in a position to
correct you
you know Republicans always laugh when
the other side says that climate change
is going to affect economic productivity
well it turns out if it's negative 60
degrees with the wind chill and you
can't even step outside because if
you're out for a few minutes you'll get
frostbite and hypothermia you're not
gonna want to go to work you know you're
going
call out or it's just gonna be canceled
for the day there's gonna be less
productivity yesterday we did a story on
the bonus show of the largest utility
provider in California having to go
bankrupt over liabilities having to do
with the California wildfires so this
stuff does the impact the economy and
we're gonna see that happening much more
as the years go on unfortunately yeah
and as far as just to get back to the
climatology piece because of course the
economic impact piece is a major one you
it's it's so I still see it on Facebook
and in the YouTube comments where people
say if we're experiencing global warming
why is it so cold why is it record cold
and of course it's like you're five
layers away from the truth number one
we're talking about warming of some
elements of the planet in connection
with climate change this includes
because of depletion of ozone warming
oceans acidification okay and any
serious climate change model would
predict that you would have erratic
weather I've said it a million times I
know this would include higher highs and
lower lows and it's all consistent with
that 99.98% of peer-reviewed studies on
this issue so that's that it's getting
boring but we actually can't just give
up on the issue because the reticence to
really make political progress on this
is in part related to the fact that you
still have a lot of people in this
country who votes who simply don't
believe the science and that's a major
major problem former New Jersey Governor
Chris Christie Christie said to Margaret
Hoover that Jared Kushner's father
committed one of the most loathsome
disgusting crimes that Christie ever
prosecuted in the state if you're not
aware of this backstory between chris
Christie and Jared Kushner's family what
it relates to is that when Christie was
a prosecutor a US Attorney in New Jersey
he actually went after Jared Kushner's
father for a sort of blackmail operation
wherein Kushner's father hired a
prostitute if I recall correctly to
seduce his brother-in-law and then
send it to his send a videotape of it to
his sister to try to intimidate her from
testifying before a grand jury I'm kind
of going vaguely in any case chris
Christie was the one involved in the
prosecution of that and now that Chris
Christie has much more directly just
said listen I think the shutdown was a
disaster he said that too I believe it
was Stephen Colbert and he is being much
more direct about the failings of Trump
it's pretty damn clear to me here Pat
that Christie does not like Kushner
Christie now blames Kushner for having
Christie sort of separated from the
transition of Donald Trump and there is
bad blood between those guys yeah the
initial crime committed by Jared
Kushner's dad had to do with campaign
finance violations and tax evasion but
the secondary crime or the witness
tampering hiring of prostitutes who hook
up with his own brother-in-law so he
could commit some witness tampering
that's certainly the more interesting
part of the story and it shows to me
that chris Christie has given up on his
dream of working within the Trump
administration like well it seems clear
that Trump was not going to win that
Hillary Clinton was going to win the
2016 election Chris Christie was chosen
as the transition head because there was
just this pie in the sky idea that
Trump's gonna win and chris Christie
will be the person in charge of the
transition then when Trump actually won
chris Christie was ousted right away and
it goes to show that it looks like
people in Trump's family his own brother
his own son-in-law are going to win that
fight and I don't think chris Christie
has a shot of ever entering this
administration and that's sad that's too
bad when these things happen
I always start to have a bit of like a
re I feel like the image of some of
these Republicans gets rehabilitated
we're now unlike you know Christie's
making a lot of sense he made sense on
Stephen Colbert he's making sense to
some degree speaking to conservative
margit Margaret Hoover in this interview
and I feel like that's sort of dangerous
because I mean okay
Christie is not like the worst
Republican by any means he's a New
Jersey Republican and I would choose him
over many other Republicans but it's
sort of a danger to feel as though they
are rehabilitated in their image merely
because they come out and say some basic
uncontroversial truths of
Donald Trump Christie's still a guy who
has done a lot of horrible stuff and I
feel like we need to be particularly
vigilant about not allowing ourselves to
you know when we think of george w bush
as a guy who at least read books and
listen to advisors that's fine he was
still a horrible neocon Warhawk but he
didn't do things as nutty as Trump when
it comes to decorum and sort of the
day-to-day yeah this happened first with
Sean Spicer and then it happened with
Omarosa and then now it's happening with
Chris Christie once they defect from
Trump they come out and they write a
book and they say some controversial
things criticizing the president and
they get a lot of praise for it in you
know even liberals progressives will
sometimes embrace them because they've
seen the light I don't like to do that
stuff we have to keep in mind how bad
these people were and in many cases
still are I tend to agree I tend to
agree with that and a period I mean I
don't think we have to say more just
don't allow the sort of romanticizing of
these past horrible people don't allow
yourself also the the bar it's it's
human nature when the bar is dragged
down so low by someone like Donald Trump
all of a sudden a whole bunch of people
that aren't as bad seem to be we could
tolerate that but remember if they were
actually in power they'd be doing a
whole host of other horrible things that
we would all be against that does it for
today new show new bonus show tomorrow
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]